welcome to this video playing the
missing link from Antarctica yeah
probably not okay so i'm starting with
the King fee and Kings fianchetto here
say different way to continue maybe
maybe something like that okay so we get
a somewhat like a close the soil in here
with our tonight on c3 may be
interesting I know that sometimes this
is called the big clamp I don't know but
this name is coming from but I think
this is quite okay for white I've seen
games with that opening by them former
check no a minion yeah he switched a
couple of times Grandmaster movsisyan he
was a minion than czechoslovakian and
now back to a Minya okay um so why it
gets a pretty good central control here
I get md for next I guess you cannot go
b5 as I'm always attacking that on there
on c5 so let's get this up oh it's
closing down the whole business here
let's now I'm going for g 4 + f5 if
possible let's see how to how to do that
um night III and Bishop h3 maybe start
with that move
so do I co Bishop h form that's also
interesting am Bishop H form or maybe
this first looking at the beer
foursquare a little bit okay so let's go
here and possibly invade on f6 that
should be quite nice so right here four
and five ok so now f5 or not Quinn Quinn
up to H force also an idea let's try
that he might play rook a two but yeah
it's a case of what what can I do I have
to get get this attack rolling and it
looks quite nicer many pieces many
pieces involved Roxy one in case of an
attack now what is he going for c2 is
protected they can go look to a three if
you want hmm okay
yeah go out do I go f5 if it looks it
looks really dangerous not sure if it is
winning but ok let's let's push that i
know i don't know if i have time for
King h1 or moves like that so let's get
it get it going
so I also have 90 exit e5 let's take
here first and then decide I can't take
on d5 with the night that's an
interesting way to play or just taking
for the g file that looks strong really
am just for the g file and that end King
age 14 root g 1 yep that's that should
be it good simple and good root g one
coming left I don't see a defense I
don't see a defense at all now White has
many pieces already am like concentrated
on the on the on the Kings side and
closing down the Queen side is some I
don't know probably probably not the way
to go look G 1 hmm
yeah so um let's see Queen takes is also
good now then he has got 97 so I wanted
to do this in the first place and I'm
going to do it now that's just ok I'm
here night g5 should do the trick h6 and
then yeah everything night f7 is winning
on rupee eight is also pretty good what
is best here night f7
rookie ideas check on a one is this
important Maya just has two checks
actually can go all the way up there and
then it's made so ok that is winning
check check 2 f 3 f and that's it no
more checks my default checking Valley
resign ok yeah I can also go to f1 if
everything else fails or here actually
that's the best one there's no check
anymore and yeah like here canning
pickles and it's made made in a couple
yeah this the setup is not bad at all
this is the setup for white white has a
good central control and have some
chances to build up a big pond and porn
center I really am unsure is this is a
great setup here allowing the c5 it just
looks like this yet looks like a passive
French defense with white having quite a
bit of space on the King side and it's
very easy to play I put put all those
pieces there any other King around here
I mean it's definitely not easy to play
for him and I have a half chances ok I
wonder the computer is not convinced
yeah it just gives white a slight
advantage but the computer is defending
mercilessly this is probably wrong I
don't know ok three years there engine
moving also what I expected just have to
get some kind of counter play and then
this one
it still feels very dangerous and the
evaluation of the engine goes up if you
give it some time it goes up probably
maybe the tech that white is going to
going to get it is a horizon problem
after a couple of more time to calculate
it sees how dangerous this and this is
actually winning already yeah he cannot
defend any more like plus 2 by the
engine Bishop Jake's yeah exactly this
is winning and this is plus 7 so
probably a major system yeah I think in
general it is rather risky to to close
the center against the set up and giving
white this big this victim space on the
King side where you don't have a subject
lee account to play at the moment so i
don't i don't think black should go for
that and today is you know this should
be seven you should see 80 he lost a
little bit more time and it added adds
up in the long run okay well thanks for
watching